studio kills on college
[Music]
I hope these videos didn't turn into
rich performs monologues and cars just
be talking and driving but I guess
that's part and parcel of living in LA
or in your car life so I recently got
back from Sweden where I was immersed in
this insane ultra endurance swim run
race it was very all consuming it was
amazing it was extraordinary and then I
came back home and immediately shifted
gears and the pendulum swung from one
extreme to the next and I've been
immersed in a different kind of ultra
endurance event which is trying to write
this book final stages of completing a
rewrite of finding ultra the second
edition of finding ultra new chapters
about 30% new material and it's due in
three days four days so I've been
writing around the clock I've barely
been sleeping my door to my container
has been shut I've barely seen sunlight
and other than the celebration the other
night I honestly have barely even gone
outside so today this afternoon
have a chance an opportunity to go do
something cool
[Music]
so excited to talk to you thank you for
making the time oh I'm so happy to be
talking to you it's great to see you
face to face I'm glad that the person
who is the forward facing person of
happiness is happy there's so many
things I want to talk to you about of
course the new book we're gonna unpack
all the archetypes that you have that
you have determined that are helping so
many people but I think one what I
wanted to kind of explore a little bit
with you first myself being a recovering
lawyer writer yeah yeah it's a lot of us
do people ask you about how you
transitioned out of this law practice um
because I mean you weren't just some
lawyer I mean you've had like a big
career in law Supreme Court Clerk and
yeah FCC and there's a whole trajectory
built into that lucky because I don't
know about you and the people that you
know maybe who've transitioned out of
law or out of anything
sometimes people know where they want to
leave but they don't know yet where they
want to go and so they have to figure
out where to go and that's hard that was
me
yeah but so I was lucky because I had
this project that was pulling me so hard
I I wanted it wasn't so much that I
wanted to leave law but that I just
wanted to devote myself to this writing
project in in you know totally I was you
know kind of absorbing these ideas it
made me reflect back on my own path like
I've undergone a tremendous amount of
change professionally emotional like a
lot of change in my life over the last
10 20 years but I didn't change my core
fundamental nature right right but I
think what I was doing and I think this
might be something that's common to a
lot of people is I was structuring my
life in accordance with a tendency that
was not my yeah myself in a situation
that didn't allow me yes to fully embody
and Express the positive aspects of that
core nature and that tendency but see
this the most important thing like you
put your finger right on the key thing
which is we all have to construct the
life that's right for us there is no one
best way there's no magic
one-size-fits-all solution because like
what works for you isn't gonna be what
works for me because you and I are
different and so we always have to begin
if we want to be happier healthier more
productive
more creative it's like okay well what
kind of person are you where do you
thrive what works for you and not to try
to jam ourselves into somebody else's
conception of what we should be able to
do or what is the best thing to do it's
like it doesn't matter what works for
somebody else or what you should be able
to do it's like it only matters what
works for you I think we did it thank
you thank you so fun to talk to you
thanks for having me on your show do
okay this is so fun I feel like we can
talk all day long she makes my job so
easy because she's such a such an adapt
conversationalist like it's just it's a
conversation is like playing tennis and
you're only as good as your partner
allows you to be
[Music]
Gretchen's basic premise is that
everybody manifests one of four general
tendencies either you're an upholder in
a blodger a questioner or a rebel
I am definitely an upholder with a light
dusting of rebel so what I think is
really interesting and important about
kind of cultivating a greater
understanding about these archetypes is
that it helps you to better understand
what motivates you what motivates other
people and I think it gives you a
framework to be able to better
understand what makes not only yourself
tick but other people tick and also it
informs how to best communicate with
other people
in any event thanks for watching really
fun to be back on this YouTube platform
let us know in the comments section
below
what you would like me to share with you
guys and David and I will give it some
consider thought in the meantime hit
that subscribe button and I'll see you
guys back here in a couple days peace
plants
[Music]